late on Christmas Day most visitors had
already left California's San Francisco
Zoo someone reported seeing young men
roaring at the Lions but no one
mentioned seeing anything out of the
ordinary at the tiger grotto an hour
later one 17-year old boy and one
Siberian tiger were dead
we have deemed the site as a blast night
a crime scene we want to it the incident
was international news cool beer
dhaliwal aged 23 and his brother Paul
aged 19 were both attacked by the
escaped tiger their friend Carlos Souza
jr. was killed his family and friends
mourned his death the city shut down too
soon the tragedy raised serious
questions about how and why dangerous
animals are kept in captivity if you had
asked me the day before was it adequate
for holding animals I would have told
you yes obviously it wasn't
the grotto measured 56 feet long by 76
feet wide it's dry moat was 29 feet
across and 12 feet 9 inches deep it had
always safely kept Tigers apart from the
viewing public until now the tiger that
escaped was named tatianna
she was a four year old 243 pound female
she had been bred for strong genes and
was acquired by the San Francisco Zoo
when she was two years old there were
few clues as to how the tiger escaped or
why she killed the zoo's veterinarian
dr. Freeland Unger conducted the animal
equivalent of an autopsy called a
necropsy on tatyana dunker found no
evidence of trauma or illness before the
escape but the Tigers claws did reveal
information about how she got out the
front claws were not frayed she didn't
like grab on something and then pull
down she was already up her hind legs
were overused to allow her to gain the
traction to get up and out her first
attempt was successful it appears
was one of the shortest days of the year
and darkness came quickly it happened as
they got down from the exhibit rail
Paul heard a sound in the bushes Tiger
was out
a newspaper reported that cool beer and
Carlos succeeded in stopping the moment
but the tiger turned on Carlos the
attack was fatal
Paul was badly injured bleeding from
wounds on his head and neck the tiger
followed their trail the men arrived at
the recently closed Terrace Cafe their
pleas for help went unanswered at 5:21
p.m. cool beer called 9-1-1
within minutes the police were moving
toward the cafe so was the tiger
when police arrived at the cafe
the tiger was sitting next to cool beer
his brother Paul was lying wounded
nearby
the tiger moved toward the police the
incident itself took place in less than
20 minutes the police department was
called in unfortunately the animal was
you know was killed the first deadly
escape in American zoo history was over